you pitch Larry ideas sometimes I put
some ideas all the time no one my one
idea was when Game of Thrones went away
it was a void left in HBO yeah I said
why don't we do a medieval season
medieval Curb Your Enthusiasm I'm not
that's hilarious that's great yeah I
would wonder I said I want to be a
dragon kind of love dragons I'll be a
perfect dragon man I'm dragging a talk
[ __ ] and blows fire you can't just do
this after any idea I really feel like
you could say any idea then go huh - see
ya did he go for that idea no he said
was dumb till the dumbass idea I like I
like picture bits of my ideas once in a
while once on my pictures one idea just
really happened so my wife went to a ENT
ears nose and throat doctor because yeah
finger yeah and while she was sitting
there - God you know it's filthy I don't
know what he felt the ENT meaning he was
recommended to us but he was filthy
he wasn't sloppy he would just grab even
open a drawer just grab tools and
immediately open your mouth and it's
like my wife's like hey hey you didn't
wash that off
yeah that's filthy that's gonna rinse it
off first yeah oh yeah right right here
it off Oh when the doctor goes oh yeah
right that's not a good idea yeah so
this guy came highly recommended so
here's the thing that threw me off I'm
sitting in a room with her I'm like
watching him you know he had hung
depressed yeah and then he says I mean
you know what I mean let me grab
something so he went to the top cabinet
and he's goes to the top cabinet like
this and his his shirt he had a smock on
yeah and a smock came up right and his
his underwear was sticking out of his of
his pants
yeah and his
this is an elastic on his underwear was
separated from ripped off his underwear
was falling apart it was falling apart
right in front of me and this man
operated a doctor yes right he said
first I said this guy's guilty then I
thought to myself who is his wife that
allows this man to walk around with
underwear right that's separating the
whole elastic was basically off from
here to the middle of his back yeah it's
disgusting
how do you be a good Curb Your
Enthusiasm also would Richard - Larry I
did and what'd he say Larry said I know
that doctor that's my doctor we have a
clip here from Curb Your Enthusiasm I
think this is a clip where you're trying
to you're trying to hitch a ride on a
private plane flight is that right
I don't know what happens you're
supposed to know what happens in the
clip sometimes it works I'm thinking
about the Hat oh wait I don't I don't
like no like no one to clip sometimes I
wanna be surprised
[Applause]
let's look at this clip I don't know
what's gonna happen
try to curb your enthusiasm bored out
let's make it easy alright okay alright
alright yeah I can do it love the idea
let's do it yeah you're not invited to
the wedding
I'm going to tag along too oh yeah chip
in you want to tag along you chip in
tell you what
consider me your luggage I've been
playing put a seat belt around me
I won't say by the way luggage doesn't
eat or talk what's the pin you got
always a point yeah
yes I have like our brains should be
programmed with a whole like maybe ten
five to ten automatic points to make get
you out of a ticket get to get you out I
tobert the lady or whatever or or you
were in bed with a lady and the night is
too short
oh whatever you'd need a point to me
every man needs ten points I'll just
memorize that you can just no not
memorize automatic wait what's the
difference I thought of that you could
just you should know them in your head
wait what do you mean you know what this
age of technology you mean to tell me
there's no way of putting a chip in a
man's brain oh oh oh this won't give you
the ability to make a point really quick
make a point make a point or the point
to that put a little point you need to
make a point once in a while you get
your ass out of trouble
so you point to the net at the point at
the point we're at a time
that gets me out all right well I want
to make sure I mentioned Curb Your
Enthusiasm it airs Sundays at 10:30 why
are you acting like I'm telling you news
that you're just I think I'm gonna be
honest I'm a fan of the show I'm a fan
you're a fan of Kirby aunty's yeah I
don't even I'm tell you when I shoot my
scenes I leave I should have seen
I can tell out of it I'm gonna watch it
like a real fan so I don't care who the
guest is I don't care what a special
guest I don't care about none of that
stuff when I watch it I'm watching it
for the first time like everybody else
Wow that's weird
yeah so at 10:30 on HBO JB Smoove
[Applause]